[Music]
one Disney logo is not enough you must
also endure the old-timey throwback
Micky logo both as well San fransokyo
Wow with the placement of the
asian-inspired Golden Gate Bridge
Alcatraz Island in the downtown area
this is clearly San Francisco but with
Tokyo on top of it which is cool I'm
down I just want to know what happened
to the Pacific Ocean is all or is this
movie like The Watchmen where we're
living in a world where we lost world
war two our San Franciscans so liberal
that they said you know what we have a
huge Japanese population only failure to
rename the whole city born Disney tries
to push another real steel on us like we
aren't going to notice that literal
protagonists name is literal well at
least one animated film with a good cop
bad cop character got nominated for an
Oscar Tadashi ex machina you graduated
high school in year 13 and this is what
you're doing this is the perfect time
for this kind of exposition and how are
they hearing each other extremely
convenient ramp shows up at the exact
spot where they need it what the hell is
this doing here anyway
fighting is illegal with so many bot
fights happening all over the city it's
amazing Tadashi found you with the one
you were at also aunt Cass goes from
caring about these kids activities to
not existing at all in order to
facilitate their sneaking out a second
time how did you not know he wasn't
going to the bond fight way before this
resistance faster bike it'll allow the
chick from premium rush to get her kid
into the country three times faster than
the last time honey lemon Go Go wasabi
okay I'm going to do something really
different and be extremely nitpicky here
I know these kids are nerds but the guy
spilled blood sabi on his shirt and this
was deemed hilarious and embarrassing
enough to base a whole nickname around
it good thing these guys weren't around
when I was younger all right be called
sour cream and onion dressing DPI X
comics I'm actually allergic to that you
are not allergic to bacitracin you do
have a mild allergy to peanuts you could
tell that just by scanning him Jesus
well he hasn't Tadashi already become
insanely rich and won the Nobel Prize
with this thing yet you have been a good
boy
have a lollipop hilarious but where did
he get the lollipop
how does baymax deflate like this with
the carbon fibers
and inside it put them together kid who
knows who this famous scientist is
somehow doesn't know what the man looks
like all these crumpled papers show that
hero is addictive trees and never got
Microsoft Word or even a notepad
installed in his computer microphone
feeds back to accentuate the awkwardness
cliche but got no problem with these
microbots since we're gonna sci-fi a
comic-book cartoon except the part where
he says these things are controlled with
your mind like even under the best of
circumstances where you're concentrating
at a perfect level how does that
communicate to all these little pots the
exact specifications you want and what
if your girlfriend breaks up with you on
the day you use these and all they can
construct as a broken wing if you can
think it the microbots can do it so this
kid invented nanobots only bigger
roughly tons of years after the
invention of nanobots Robert I know how
you feel about me we find out later that
Krane neglected safety when it came to a
transportation portal which callaghan's
daughter test piloted and never came
back because this needs to be a surprise
for the audience Cray talks to Callaghan
like they don't have a history together
and Callaghan talks about grey like he's
simply some greedy businessman there's
virtually no reason why do dashi and
Hiro decide to hang back other than to
have that unnecessary brother moment and
so they can be around when the
exposition center catches fire I was
just gonna tell you your fly was down
for the whole show uh-huh
but if his fly is down here it is not
remotely visible from the audience's
position Hanson there someone has to
help like Aquaman I can't believe this
extremely smart guy thinks he can run
into a burning building and expect
anything but tragedy oh all my microbots
are in there and my brother as usual no
sad moments can happen without earth
dumping rain on everyone also only black
umbrellas are allowed at a funeral
cliche okay when I touch it healthcare
robot is programmed to continue medical
exam even after patient rates paying a
zero on a scale of one to ten you should
expect an increase in body hair
especially on your face chest armpits
amazingly the robot baymax thus far
unfazed by any kind of protest actually
stops talking so this movie can keep its
PG rating Hiro was so unnecessarily
beyond embarrassed about baymax a
discussion about puberty he stupidly
jumps on him to try and deflate him
which of course leads to a new discovery
under the bed
we've seen these micro BOTS do amazing
things but getting out of a jacket
pocket is something that is above its
pay grade
your tiny robot is trying to go
somewhere
damn you baymax you've been on screen a
total of about three minutes so far but
you've already hit adorable levels
worthy of one sin reduction
wait did baymax just walk through the
cafe without anyone seeing it yes there
is absolutely no reason why he wrote
acts like baymax is et and needs to keep
his aunt from knowing anything about it
there was nothing whatsoever on the line
if she finds out about it how long did
baymax get on the trolley
does he have coins paper currency is
money obsolete in this weird-ass fusion
future no one thinks it's curious that a
white inflatable blob is walking around
town Wilhelm scream heart attack my
hands are equipped with defibrillators
you know what that's funny but if you're
gonna know for a fact that he has
allergies to peanuts just by scanning
him surely you can tell he didn't
literally have a heart attack flying
robots with stolen cop seems skeptical
about flying robots despite the two
minute display of baymax is obvious
weird robot abilities and awareness by
the way is this the age of Minority
Report where no crimes are being
committed anymore
this is one empty police station or
maybe the villain from bad boys is
planning to rob it and Cass apparently
has never seen anyone act suspicious
before hero kills a 30-pound count by
throwing it up an entire flight of
stairs did baymax charge all the way
back up in like a minute let's work on
your moves movie clearly and
deliberately rips off the matrix luckily
this movie hero put in so that baymax
can learn karate is a side-scrolling one
take action shot that will motion
capture all the moves a robot designed
to help people with healthcare and
that's it of course has multiple ports
where you can stick other programming
chips
is definitely amusing and I hate to be a
killjoy but did he need a robot to get
him gummy bears out of the vending
machine I am I'm an asshole this car
notices them and stops to investigate
amazing timing considering who it turns
out to be slowest baymax was able to
catch up to Hiro before he blindly fell
into the ocean car that has been
suspiciously following Hiro this whole
time just turns out to be his friends
who could have simply called out to him
instead of being a bunch of stalking
assholes meanwhile the mysterious masked
figure who has all the microbots and is
moving all sorts of shit around is gone
deadly quiet don't push us away heat'll
we're here for you that's why baymax
contacted us so and we waited for hours
before actually driving out to see you
so that we could get mixed up into the
plot holy mother I'm here they just took
a lot of TJ Miller's outtakes from
Cloverfield and put it into this movie
seriously she took a picture with flash
and everything she really just did that
movie chair as a car chase page from
Fast and Furious where only the good
guys and bad guys are out at night and
there is zero traffic super scary Mike
robot villain is only fast enough to
barely keep pace with the Chevy sedan
villain throws a car instead of simply
catching up to them which should be
possible with his amazing army of
microbots movie that pretends to care
about science proceeds to make this
possible these tires should be freakin
dead by now skidding against the grain
like that for the second time the master
villain assumes the heroes are dead and
wanders off stupidly either that or his
intent was only to scare them all along
in which case he carried on for far too
long
movie thinks it can slip a Stan Lee
cameo buy us like we're just gonna let
that slide nice try assholes you got the
TV cued up to this dude before you ever
came in here I hear a song which means
montage time does Tony Stark know that
some kid in futuristic San fransokyo has
a pirated version of his gadget creation
software first iron man's hand gesture
creation computer Tron girl and now mr.
Incredibles I'm too fat to fit into my
suit moment this movie is ripping off
all the Disney actually since baymax is
mostly air he should pop when this
happens right
we saw him intentionally let out air
earlier to squeeze through a window why
is he not doing that now to help the
suit fit which reminds me does he still
have six pieces of scotch tape holding
all that air in because amazing if so
Scott to tape doesn't last more than a
day everyone knows that he gave everyone
a weapon except the dark haired chick
who gets skates
I'd like to introduce baymax 2.0 B Max
is an awesome robot and an awesome
character but this Armour once again
illustrates the bizarre
for Marvel to make a mechanical robot
badass in every one of their movies also
that's the Iron Man suit awesome why you
didn't create cap shield and Thor's
hammer for other members of the team
I'll never know baymax steals the odd
job from Goldfinger moody can't resist
it's in Harry Potter and has baymax fly
through San fransokyo basically just to
show off the IMAX 3d stuff you overpaid
for all these movies have a scene like
this pretending to justify the need for
the technology this is still going I
honestly just counted 20 movies with the
scene like this in my head during this
scene I figured I'd miss something I
would have to ask the 7 year old kicking
my seat for a plot update but nope now
baymax can scan an entire city from this
range and figure out everyone's health
statistics the scanner is way more
amazing than almost anything else in
this movie even microbots but it'll only
be used for this one scene and never
heard from again
none of the New Teen Heroes kill each
other and this seizure of itchy trigger
finger reaction assault also didn't even
kill the thing that made the noise
somehow but cute pigeon guys you might
want to see this you might want to see
this cliche also once again bad guys are
leaving doors open for anyone to peek
inside their criminal operation all the
visual information they need to know is
ready to watch at the push of a button
Oh what the hell throw a little Stargate
in there to regulate e in the magnetic
field that a rich guy or scientist
ignores causes death and/or villain
spawning cliche and a dash of spider-man
to Jesus this movie is a casserole of
other movies ideas having failed earlier
to kill them by throwing a car villain
spins the prize wheel of attacks and
once again lands on the throwing heavy
at people and hoping they die pi which
also for the second time in this film
villain leaves heroes for dead without
checking to ensure they're dead
explosion died no I had your microbots
which are explosion proof also who
started the fire
you can cue the Billy Joel music while
we figure this out I guess Callahan did
because he knew the microbots would
protect them as he birthed his revenge
scheme you're gonna have faith so you
can cue George Michael now cuz I gotta
have faith nobody steals the robot
temporarily turns bad scene from The
Iron Giant now that he's turned evil
baymax also does what the bull villains
always do and that's wait so long to
attack their plans are foiled at the
last minute and because Hiro
uncharacteristically suddenly decided to
kill the professor a convenient
pandemonium ensued that allowed the bad
guy to get the mask back voila
screenwriting 101 people
my enhanced scanner has been damaged of
course it has it fulfilled its one use
and now it's worthless wait you mean
this robot can actually keep its access
port closed things like that mechanical
what power does he have on the inside of
his body to keep that port shut but
maybe don't leave your team stranded on
a spooky island next time oh man it's
cool he picked us up in the family
chopper somehow we were able to get here
in the 4 minutes you've been in this
garage we found something you should see
damn 20% of this girl's lines or you
should look at this cliches speaking of
which nearly all the characters that are
not baymax are nearly worthless in this
movie what distinguishes these
characters that make me want to see more
of their pilot was callaghan's daughter
a tragic story he never shared with
anyone because he knew one day some kid
would build him something which he could
use to get revenge you have to keep your
supposedly dead zone or a secret somehow
I guess he told everyone she went on
vacation or something you took
everything from me when you sent Abigail
into that machine now I'm taking
everything from you this is the most
elaborate I for and I revenge plan ever
conceived what was he gonna do it Hiro
never invented those microbots because I
would've gone with that plan oh thank
God for rebar it's always handy whenever
you're about to die how does Callaghan
have the ability to take on multiple
people at once using the microbots he's
got to do this all with his head
splitting attention between all the
different heroes coming at him from all
different directions
tons of killer debris flies into the
portal but misses Hiro completely and
he's in the dead center of the pole you
mean they haven't been trying to come up
with new angles this whole time yeah I
Regulus Li just because Hiro tells them
this all of them come up with solutions
everyone survives this my sensor is
detecting signs of life Abigail has been
subsisting on balrog dreams and fairy
dust whilst in another dimension the
portal is destabilizing she's alive in
there someone has to help hey those are
the same words Tadashi used when he
stupidly went into that burning building
but now they sound heroic
I mean doubly stupid considering what
happened to Tadashi the portal is
destabilizing but baymax wastes all this
time showboating around before flying
into it wasn't this a matter transporter
between two places this part of the
movie suggests the contraption first
transports you to some weird space he
alternate dimension place and then you
have to find the second portal to get
out
which means Crais actually invented more
than a teleportation device he invented
a wormhole or an alternate universe
alright simply giving Direction commands
would be worthless in the debris field
without also giving instructions on how
far or for how long to veer left and
right hero sacrifices himself to save
the world click well he's saving two
people not the world still sacrificing
himself with a greater good and the Iron
Giant did this too they did that just at
the moment it exploded if he rode whined
about anything else for just one more
second they would have died a mess I
mean you can't build another one you
assholes have built a million things in
this movie just as impressive as baymax
and you make it sound like a kind of her
build him again meanwhile wouldn't
Tadashi have saved his work somewhere he
didn't have a laptop with all the work
on it he just saved everything to that
one chip who are we
spider-man he Incredibles the Avengers
the Fantastic Four oh now there are six
more you assholes I got to keep track of
even the end credits scene rips off
spider-man to Fred's dan has the most
amazing timing ever and shows up at the
exact same time fred found this secret
room
stanley isn't content to cameo in a
painting you are satisfied we don't care
[Music]
this is not possible inconceivable mine
let me go I'll give you anything you
want your personal healthcare companion
hello I am baymax your personal
healthcare companion
[Music]
can't lose you to hero
no following oh man weights my brother
sees you you're gonna help so many
people buddy you're gonna be a bad
motherfucker